[Music]
you'll be on the red carpet this Sunday
talking to all the nominees at this
year's award yes I will have you voted
yet I go to long time you did okay me
too I'm very excited to see what happens
of course this is the show where actors
honor each other so how will it be
different here are the SAG Awards by the
numbers you know there's a lot of ladies
involved the show's first ever host
Kristen Bell isn't kidding all-female
presenters will announce the 13 acting
categories yesterday we got a look at 86
star-studded tables Sunday's going to
being ladies night let's call Table
eight the wonder women presenters Halle
Berry Goldie Hawn and her daughter Kate
along with nominated co-stars Jane Fonda
and Lily Tomlin they do not pick where
they're gonna sit we select where
they're gonna sit table 19
no big little lie is all girl power
Reece McCall and a reunion for
downsizing nominee Hong chow who's also
had a role on the HBO series but who's
the guy that gets to switch tables
Timothy sha'lame who's both with Lady
Bird and called me by your name we put
the two tables as close as we could
together so he could jump from one to
the other on the menu for the 1278
guests chicken salmon and a whole lot to
drink including wine we brought a lot
about 130 cases so 2,000 bottles 80
bottles of tequila and between 70 and 75
bottles of vodka back to Kristen Bell we
now know how she's getting beautified
for Sunday thanks to her husband Jack
Shephard will you please tell people
this is real that is actually an LED
Beauty mask you know the light to
generate collagen and make you all glowy
and fabulous for the red carpet but Dax
prefers to call it electronic monster
[Music]
you
[Music]